[Music]
here's the thing about Wilin eyes like
we are family is that's never going down
it's just not it's not gonna happen ever
Jada pinkett-smith on Sirius XM sway in
the morning shutting down pesky rumours
that she and hubby of more than 20 years
Will Smith are headed for splitsville we
are family like take out all that whole
marriage relationship crap at the end of
the day what will and I our family I'm
going to hold him down it doesn't matter
all that relationship and what people
think ideas of a husband and a partner
and all that man whatever at the end of
the day that's a man cat that can rely
on me for the rest of his life period
expect more candid conversation from
Jada
about her relationship on her Facebook
watch show read Table Talk she told et
in April a marriage themed episode with
coming soon women I actually gonna have
a very interesting conversation about
how our journey in regards to
transforming a marriage into a life
partnership there's no doubt the 46 year
old actress loves having her hubby
around last summer she gushed to et
about how much she enjoyed having him on
set while shooting girls trip I love it
when wills on set with me because it
just makes me feel relaxed you
I mean I feel like whenever he's there
everything's gonna be okay
you know so I just I gave real mushy
because he's there and I just I just
feel taken care of
[Music]